موظفون بدوام كامل وبدوام جزئي في الولايات المتحدة.
العمل بمعدل 40 ساعة في
الأسبوع وفقًا لبيانات عام 2017 الصادرة عن
مكتب إحصاءات العمل ولكن العمل
أكثر من ذلك مرتبط
بالتغيرات السلبية في صحتك أثناء
العمل لساعات أقل كل أسبوع يمكن أن يساعد في
جعلك أكثر صحة وفقًا لبحث
من جامعة نيويورك لانجون  الصحة هنا أربع
طرق يمكن أن يساعد أسبوع العمل الأقصر في
تحسين صحتك ، حيث
وجدت دراسة نشرت في مجلة
الطب النفسي أن
العمل لأكثر من 55 ساعة في الأسبوع كان
مرتبطًا بأعراض القلق
والاكتئاب بين الأشخاص الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 44 و 66
عامًا.  الموظفون بدوام كامل أولئك الذين يعملون بدوام كامل
لديهم مخاطر أقل من هذه
الأعراض للنوم أكثر. قلة النوم
قد تؤدي إلى ضعف أداء الذاكرة
وصعوبة في معالجة المعلومات.
قلل من خطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب
التاجية بين البالغين و 4 يقضون
وقتًا أطول مع أحبائهم يمكنهم المساعدة في
مكافحة مرض الشريان التاجي  الكذب وتشجيع الشخص
على الانخراط في الأنشطة الترفيهية
وممارسة الرياضة في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا
كيم هاتشرسون